uh oh
it sounds like their feelings why the
[ __ ] would we respect men
they're lit there are like they're
literally if we were put out in nature
they're the ones we should fear oh my
God this woman's dog definitely stepped
on a bee so I don't know if you know
this but we are in nature this is not a
simulation and most men are not preying
on anything except for Little Caesar's
extra most bestest and the Gargoyles and
Eldon ring but I'm gonna let you finish
believe them if I can get like their
wallet to be empty and mine and empty
their pockets yeah I'll take it
reparations [ __ ] also like when I was
making the mistake of [ __ ] men I
didn't hear what they wanted to say I
didn't want to listen they're dumb I
don't respect them when I would make the
mistake of [ __ ] them I would
literally cover their mouth because I
was like Boo Boo I don't give a [ __ ]
you're a piece of meat for me
let's get this over with because I need
to you know you need to make me not
finish so I can finish I swear they are
finding the most creative ways to tell
on themselves this isn't even like if
you squint you can kind of see the
predatory behavior it is right there it
is a giant red flag Factory and it's
almost like she realized how bad it
sounded at the end of the year she
started stuttering hurry up and make me
not finish so I can finish being here
like I guess at least you don't respect
yourself either everything she just
described about her own behavior is her
being the predator and then look at this
follow-up clip why would I willingly let
a man into my life so I knew be [ __ ]
over so I can be manipulated Oh you mean
exactly the thing that you said you do
to men you really managed to wrap up
that projection in a pretty little bow
didn't you and they all love to justify
this with the whole well-mended at first
so that's the only reason I'm doing it
thing the whole Chicken and the Egg
thing doesn't matter because you're both
chickens like do you see what I'm saying
here if your response to seeing people
behave like Monsters is to become a
monster you're not a better monster and
I'm gonna be very real with you if you
are indeed covering a men's mouths
during intercourse against their consent
to silence them I hope you get slapped
with every essay conviction in the book
Something tells me you going to prison
would be a win-win for all of us you can
finally be in a place where there are no
men and men can be in a place where
they're safe from predators like you
scary
jeez
I'm actually scary why it's not scary
okay I just think scary all the time
tonight it's just scary how
actually Predators them so you got me
like that is actually a predator right
there that's Basics man
you're gonna see some real Predators I'm
talking alien V Predator Predators like
they can go invisible stuff
yeah what did you think of the stuff she
was saying
like about how she feels about me
is
a lot like
I'm still processing it I never knew
women actually no I did know but to that
extreme covering a man's mouth and
being the most that's great power that
is that's great yeah she definitely has
a therapy so absent right clearly that's
all I thought she's paying someone a lot
of money
just so that they could not finish how
come is that still on Tick Tock as well
because it's okay to say stuff like that
about yeah it's not right and you can
cancel Andrew take like right now like
feminism is a hate group and and we
haven't treated it as a head group so
we've normalized it so that's like our
default message
um and everything you know outside of
that is obviously well I've said that a
lot of feminists have chosen to become
just like some of the worst types of men
in history yeah but you know what I mean
it's like there's been really bad men in
history but what you've done to say oh
my thing is to get even with men and
become just like like she said just like
the monster they want to become like the
worst types of an in history and they
think that's quote unquote equality
yeah they're taking their power back
I've feminists have said that to me at
one point I said something like taking
that power back yeah it's like oh and
this is funny all right this is this is
when I saw the timeline of a feminist
and I always love when I did this this
was in uni this is the Cambridge girl
and it was interesting because she was
gorgeous and you know she cheated on her
boyfriend she spent a lot of time
justifying it and I had it I was just
observing her and at one point
um she was talking about taking her
power back by like treating men a
certain way and it was interesting
because I actually met her like later on
in like later 20s
um so it's funny to think that she was
telling me how in uni like should go
back with guys and like she wouldn't
sleep with them because she thought it
was like her being powerful and like you
know exercising her right of consent
it's funny seeing her like here they
feel like
being squared up with men is doing
something to the men when they don't
understand how they're just bringing
down us women she blew board she blew
board these guys for fun played played
with expectations wasted their nights
and she thought them and then she she
thought wow you know I can say yes or no
she took pride in that right oh wow so
it's funny to meet her later in her 20s
having difficulty attracting those men
she was telling me like yeah it's
definitely different now it was one of
the most fulfilling wholesome moments of
our relationship was like yeah yeah what
are you having sex with her no after
that just hearing hearing these
conversations you know you know pillow
talk you're like yeah I'm sure you
regret all that now yeah and she knows
she knows she was being dumb but like
you know you know they can't they can't
process things consciously so like you
say something and you can see in the
corner of her eyes that like she kind of
understands and then the feminist
program and kicks it back in again and
it's kind of like no but I preserve
better man have you guys met or dealt
with misandrists women who you know that
you know they actually don't like men
yeah and for the women have you actually
deal dealt with men who you know are
misogynists and they don't like women
yes no
no
no you said no oh yes who may yeah yeah
100 okay why would you why why or did
you find out at a later stage what the
message
um I think he I don't think it's so much
relationships it's more like friendships
or men I've seen or or men down the pub
and that sort of that sort of thing you
know no when I say deal with them in a
relationship with in a situationship
with oh yeah I think it's come from in
relationships 100 but I just thought you
meant that in gen in a general term I
mean I dealt with a
lady who was a very anti-men right she
always believed that I mean her
experiences and when she used to talk
about the partners she had been with it
was trauma
continued on on and on and when it came
down to me I'm supposed to take it all
right and then when I stood up for
myself right I was seen as the
narcissist right I was seen as the
aggressor right I was seeing as I don't
have a voice because I'm tough I'm big I
meant to take it all
the the effects of that the emotional
effects of that were quite long-lasting
because it kind of built a hatred within
me right I wasn't heard
I wasn't um allowed to have an opinion
because like I said I'm a man right
um
did you react did I ever react to her I
mean there are times when it got very
very heated
but I wouldn't definitely I wouldn't say
I reacted in a way that was can be
deemed as uh how did that make you feel
in terms of like
are you traumatized by I wasn't
traumatized but it definitely made me I
went through the motions of blaming race
first I would never date these okay you
go through the motions oh I'm never
gonna get with a person that's not fully
over and then I also had to look at
myself because before you blame anybody
you've got to start with yourself right
you attract what you are so they say so
I started thinking to myself maybe
she I was attracted
to this person because I'm probably
traumatized from something right then I
also had to question myself on oh maybe
I ignored these signs because of how
attractive she was
and you know I can take it because I
started to believe into that notion of
I'm a man I'm strong I'm this I'm that
but in fact what I was doing was
juggling everyone's emotions and
ignoring my own and it ended badly we
tried back and forth you know we we
considered um
canceling
um canceling
yeah we considered that and you know
what it was I mean when we eventually
went a bad way uh our separate ways it
was the case of
He's the bad guy
step four ghost yeah I never I never
listened you never listened to my
feelings you never listen to my emotions
and then obviously you you as a man
where we are we are pictured or we're
painted in this thing or we're not meant
to talk too much we're not supposed to
express ourselves too much because what
we do is seen as the weaker I feel like
a lot of women go into relationship
traumatized by their ex or their past
everybody does yeah puts it on to the
man and that's why you may feel that way
do you think it's like whip its own
fault though because we we pick bad guys
right I mean yeah but you can't tell
them that right they hate it they hate
it because like women women
um felons have 30 more kids than
non-felons yeah so it's like it's like
girl's a little screamo the trauma but
it's like [ __ ] true you picked a trauma
there was a Joe down the street who
would have bought you a house
my Skies someone gave me disagreement
I'm gonna try and explain it as best as
possible someone said there's a
difference between a good guy and a nice
guy no there's no difference no there is
a difference according to I hope I do
you proud she knows who she is a nice
guy is the one that really over
compensates for what you've lost in
previous situations yeah yeah roses the
whole shebang over does and the good guy
is someone who can put you in your place
he's not but you know he's not the softy
he's he's about that life if that makes
sense you know they're called the nice
guys because women don't actually
like them do you know what I mean as in
oh he's a nice guy yeah he's not with me
yeah
a woman who call a man a nice guy
because they're not attracted to them
like they they don't see themselves with
them like you can be a nice guy I mean
you can be a good guy
but a nice guy to someone else you know
what I mean because you're not attracted
to that person if that makes sense
that's what you would break it down to
yeah because you're not attracted to
that nice guy that is that's not your
fit so that's exactly so would you
so you saying women don't want Max guys
no they do yeah they want a good guy but
not a nice guy isn't because they're not
attracted to that person so it's
basically what I'm saying literally is
there one guy that doesn't exist yeah
they want the perfect mix they want an
alpha now that secretly like some kind
of feminist after yeah
please lead me I respect your decisions
and everything I just I just want to be
under you that's what they want they
just want you to lay down because that
girl said cover your mouth you may not
be like attracted to them but they might
be giving you everything you want so
that's why they call them the nice guy
do you know what I mean that's the new
using them right yeah
guys don't get it twisted women like
this is I've had a few friends like you
can just don't be the emotional bit as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible